eine autobahn baustelle auf der a 3 bei
köln arbeiter entfernen mit schwerem
gerät platten aus einer lärmschutzwand
eine scheinbar ganz normale baustelle
dabei ist der hintergrund ein tragisches
ereignis rückblick an genau dieser
stelle begrub eine tonnenschwere
betonplatte einen schwarzen polo unter
sich die 66 jährige fahrerin hatte keine
chance
am späten vormittag war sie in richtung
oberhausen unterwegs da löste sich
plötzlich eine riesige betonplatte aus
der wand und stürzte auf ihr auto
die stellungnahme der feuerwehr am
unfalltag ja die bergung der
verunfallten person gestaltet sich
relativ schwierig zunächst musste durch
fachkräfte und den straßenbaulastträger
die standsicherheit benachbarter
elemente dieser lärmschutzwand geprüft
werden
bis die feuerwehr letztendlich unter
einsatz des feuerwehrkran das
tonnenschwere betonelement vom fahrzeug
heben konnte rettungskräfte konnten der
fahrerin nicht mehr helfen sie starb
noch am unfallort nach angaben des
verkehrsministeriums war die betonplatte
im jahr 2007 fehlerhaft befestigt wurden
bei den folgenden untersuchungen kam
heraus dass das auch auf benachbarte
platten zutrifft die viel zu großen
bauteile wurden von einer improvisierten
konstruktion gehalten nun mussten auch
sie entfernt werden
offen ist ob es sich um einen einzelfall
handelt oder ob sich der schreckliche
vorfall wiederholen könnte mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
der schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren